das hier ist der beste Burger den ich
jemals gegessen habe und er hat ein
Geheimnis diese Zwiebeln aber fangen wir
erstmal mit dem Burger waren an Burger
Bann zum Butter und schön anrösten und
packe mir die Zwiebeln zieh die durch
meine Mandoline
unsere Burger buns sehen jetzt so aus
ich habe jetzt zwei Kügelchen geformt so
ungefähr 80 bis 100 Gramm und jetzt
gehen wir ordentlich Zwiebeln oben drauf
die wir dann gleich mit eins Maschen
werden warum quasi instant gegrillte
Zwiebeln und boah hat sich das mal
gegessen habe in Amerika gamechanger wir
geben die Patties drauf und jetzt messen
richtig groß die sollen schön überstehen
Salz Pfeffer nicht vergessen guckt euch
das an die Zwiebeln karamellisieren das
Petty wird von unten perfekt braun und
wenden wow perfekte Rüstung wichtig Käse
nicht irgendeine Schmelzkäse hier drüben
in der Zwischenzeit Ketchup Mario und
Gurken und ein paar rot Zwiebeln so
fertig zusammenfügen boah ich bin so
bereit dafür auf unserem Band platzieren
guckt euch das an so diese kleinen
Stückchen probieren